[Music]
what do you say to somebody when they
say can you dumb it down for me uh I
only get your take I'll give you my take
if you're interested yeah I I really
hate that phrase dummy because I think
is what a science communicate you're
trying to do is to not remove any of the
complexity of the of the topic or
whatever it's just that you're trying to
get it across in a way that someone will
understand right like you can take sort
of like Einstein's theory of relativity
and you could communicate between
astrophysicists and being like here's
what it means just by giving them an
equation and like someone would
understand that because that's a
language they're used to right is the
language of maths and tenses and vectors
and all that kind of stuff you learn and
if you do a degree in physics but if you
come across like you know Joe Jane
public on the street you're not gonna
like give them an equation
but you're not dumbing it down by
expressing that in different words at
the same time right so that's what I try
and do is is still keep the level of
complexity and like if you if I need
I'll I'll build it up with with you know
the concepts you need underlying that
but again in like the simplest way I can
and I'm always in the back of my mind
I've always got my mum right my mum is
like you know she she did high school
three phds and astrophysics it's a
relativistic particles no it's so she
did high school and then and then left
it at sort of 16 which is the age you
can leave High School in the UK and um
and that was it but she's always been
like interested and intelligent but
never educated right because there's a
difference between intelligence and and
educated right and and I think I always
think as long as my mum would understand
what I'm saying
[Music]
and I love the fact that you know for
those who who don't necessarily have the
night sky that they can enjoy or for
those who who really do get so
captivated by these questions and want
to get involved themselves citizen
science is a way for them to do that you
know okay necessarily sort of going out
in the garden observing with your
telescope every night trying to discover
an asteroid because I think sometimes
that is what drives people that sort of
desire to discover something but the
idea that you know I need help doing my
PhD but there's so much data that you
know me and my colleagues there
physically isn't enough of us to go
through it all and so you know the idea
that 300 000 people around the world
could help you with your PhD is
incredible
and so I
always sort of Lord the citizen science
whenever I can because you know I've
written papers where there's me and
maybe like eight collaborators from
Oxford Nottingham you know Chicago
Minnesota you know wherever the world
Sydney or something like that and then
300 000 other people you know and it's
like this work would not be possible
because all of these people went to a
website they saw an image of a galaxy
and they were asked is it spiral shaped
or is it round and blobish which is such
an easy question you know because image
recognition is one of those things we
can do from like a toddler right it's
one of those things that we learn as
children and so getting people involved
in that kind of science with the
knowledge that you know this science and
this result and this discovery you know
wouldn't be possible
without them I think is incredible and I
there's a great story out of the back of
one of the projects so one of the
projects was asking people to look
through Planet data
and uh the Kepler space telescope data
and it was basically sort of like we're
looking at stars and if the star's
brightness dips there might be a planet
there so can you record for us if the
brightness is dipping anywhere and it
was such a great project and so many
people got involved the idea that you
could discover a planet you know around
another star in our Milky Way that was
obviously people absolutely love that
and they did end up being someone who
had discovered a planet that like
computer algorithms could miss in the
data and he was a guy from the northeast
of England retired guy and the media
descended on his house right and were
like why did you get involved in this
like incredible project like what was it
was it the discovery that like drove you
to to do this and he was like well
there's only so much gardening you can
do and there's just not a lot on telly
lately
and it's just this retired guy and they
were like do you think you'll you've
caught the bug do you want to catch
another one and he was like no probably
not I'll probably do something different
to know that what I was spending my time
doing was useful to someone somewhere
whether it was you know classifying the
shapes of galaxies or the shapes of
craters on mars or flagging where there
are penguins and images from Antarctica
there was this huge raft of different
citizen science projects and it's it's
yeah it's a tool to get people into it
but it's also a tool to let them be
involved in science themselves
when I finished my University undergrad
I was like so lost of what to do right I
loved school and I felt bereft when I
left school right and so when I got to
University I was like phew four years at
least now I like this this is fine and
then the end of that four years I was
like bereft again not knowing what to do
because I just love learning and that
and just these holes of learning I was
just like I want to do this for the rest
of my life and I didn't realize at the
time that going into research meant you
will still be learning for the rest of
your life right because you're not
necessarily being taught anymore you're
the one figuring out the answers you
know no one's telling you the answers
anymore you're literally like writing
the textbooks it sounds like something
harder homework problems right exactly
yeah it's problems that might not have
an answer I mean you didn't know if you
find us answer this question quenching
questions until you actually did it
foreign